-In his state of the union
address this week,
President Biden made a point
to focus on kitchen table issues
that impact ordinary Americans,
like junk fees,
prescription drug costs,
and even concert prices.
And then yesterday,
House Republicans,
led by their de facto speaker,
Marjorie Taylor Greene,
decided to respond
by focusing on an issue
that really matters
to Americans --
why did Twitter censor
Hunter Biden's nudes?
[ Laughter ]
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
Say what you want about Biden,
but on Tuesday,
he made a clear choice
to focus on economic populism
as the predominant theme
of his speech.
He talked about everything
from breaking up
big tech monopolies
to capping the price
of insulin,
eliminating junk fees
at hotels and airlines,
and even cracking down
on inflated ticket prices
for concerts.
Look, I don't know for sure,
but I'm starting to think
Joe Biden might be
a secret Swiftie,
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
just sitting at his computer,
just refreshing Ticketmaster
over and over again.
"Mr. President, we need you
in the Situation Room!"
Hold your horses.
I'm number 8,000 in the queue.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I think I --
I think I got a shot.
Oh, Taylor,
look what you made me do.
[ Laughter and applause ]
In fact, there were even times
when it seemed like Biden
was maybe taking some rhetorical
flourishes from Donald Trump,
but, instead of just talking
out of his ass, like Trump does,
[ Laughter ]
Biden was backing it up
with actual policy.
-Tonight, I'm announcing
new standards require
all construction materials used
in federal
infrastructure projects
to be made in America.
[ Cheering and applause ]
And, on my watch,
American roads, bridges,
and American highways
are going to be made
with American products as well.
My economic plan is
about investing
in places and people
that have been forgotten.
Too many people
have been left behind
and treated like
they're invisible.
Outside of Columbus, Ohio,
Intel is building
semiconductor factories
on 1,000 acres.
Last year, I cracked down,
on behalf of many of you,
on foreign shipping companies
that were making you
pay higher prices
for every good coming
into the country.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Americans are tired of being --
we're tired of being played
for suckers.
-Biden basically took Trump's
rhetorical schtick,
but backed it up
with actual legislation.
He even released it
as a single, called...
[ Laughter and applause ]
The other difference is
Biden did it
without going on a bunch
of insane tangents
and exaggerating how many jobs
he was creating.
If that had been Trump,
that speech would've
been twice as long
and he would've gone
off-script after every line.
[ As Trump ]
Intel is building
a factory in Ohio.
They were going
to build it in China,
but then I became president
and I called up the CEO.
His name is Chip, Chip Intel.
[ Laughter ]
And I said, I said, "Mr. Intel,
you better build that factory
in Columbus."
Columbus! We love Columbus,
don't we?
[ Laughter ]
We love it.
Named after the great
film director Chris Columbus.
[ Laughter ]
He made -- He made the movie
"Home Alone 2:
Lost in New York,"
[ Laughter ]
a movie I originally --
I originally starred in.
They cut most of my scenes.
It was very sad.
I remember a guy named Marv
came up to me.
[ Laughter ]
Big guy, tall guy,
tears in his eyes,
iron print on his face,
and he said to me,
[ Laughter ]
"You got to help us catch
this little [bleep]."
[ Laughter ]
And, in particular,
Biden focused
on a bunch of real problems
that people face every day,
like, for example,
the high cost of essential
medications or hidden fees.
-We capped the cost of insulin
at $35 a month
[ Cheering and applause ]
for seniors on Medicare.
Let's cap the cost of insulin
for everybody at $35.
[ Cheering and applause ]
My administration is also
taking on junk fees.
We're making airlines show you
the full ticket price up front.
We've reduced exorbitant
bank overdrafts.
[ Applause ]
We're cutting credit card
late fees by 75%.
We're going to ban surprise
resort fees
that hotels charge on your bill.
[ Applause ]
We can stop service fees
on tickets to concerts
and sporting events
and make companies disclose
all the fees up front.
And we'll prohibit airlines
from charging $50 round trip
for family just to be able
to sit together.
[ Applause ]
Baggage fees are bad enough.
Airlines can't treat your child
like a piece of baggage.
-Drug prices,
Internet companies, junk fees.
He basically took everything
grandpas complain about
and turned it into a speech.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ As Biden ]
Why do they make thermostats
that go all the way up to 77°?
[ Laughter ]
Folks, we're going
to cap it at 68°
and I'm mailing every American
a sweater.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Another idea from that list
that I think most people
can probably get behind is
capping service fees on concerts
and sporting events.
I mean, we all hate it
when you click buy
on some tickets
that say they're 100 bucks,
but then, by the time
you get to checkout,
they're double the price,
after you count up all the fees
and a lot of them
don't even seem real.
It's like...
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
So, that's the kind of thing
Biden was focused on
in his speech on Tuesday.
Of course, you'll probably
also recall
the GOP heckled him
for claiming some Republicans,
like Senators Ron Johnson
and Rick Scott,
want to cut Social Security
and Medicare.
Scott and Johnson
both proposed plans
to sunset
all federal legislation,
which would include
Social Security and Medicare,
and require periodic votes
to renew them.
Right now,
those programs are mandatory,
but Johnson and Scott proposed
putting them up
for vote every five years.
Or, in Johnson's case,
every year.
And yet,
when Biden brought it up,
Republicans,
like Marjorie Taylor Greene,
called him a liar.
-Instead of making the wealthy
pay their fair share,
some Republicans --
some Republicans want Medicare
and Social Security to sunset.
I'm not saying it's a majority.
[ Booing ]
Let me give you --
Anybody who doubts it,
contact my office.
I'll give you a copy.
I'll give you a copy
of the proposal.
-You're a liar!
-That means Congress
doesn't vote --
[ Shouting ]
-Liar!
-I'm not saying
it's a majority of you.
I don't even think it's even
a significant --
-Don't speak anymore.
[ Shouting ]
-But it's being proposed
by individuals.
I'm politely not naming them,
but it's being proposed
by some of you.
-I like Biden's
passive-aggressive grandpa move
of "I'm politely
not naming them."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ As Biden ]
Look, I'm not going to say
who they are,
but one guy's named
after a penis
and the other looks like one.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Then yesterday --
yesterday, Biden showed up
at a speech in Wisconsin
with physical proof
of the Republican proposals
he had cited
from Johnson and Scott
to cut Medicare
and Social Security.
-We've had a spirited debate
last night [ Mirthless chuckle ]
with my Republican friends.
They seemed shocked...
[ Laughter ]
...when I raised the plans
of some of their members
and their caucus
to cut Social Security.
And Marjorie Taylor Greene
and others stood up and said,
"Liar, liar."
Well, guess what.
You know, I remind you
that Rick Scott, from Florida,
the guy who ran the U.S. Senate
campaign, has a plan.
I got his brochure right here.
[ Laughter ]
Has a plan.
Here's what he says
in this plan.
Let me open it up here.
Sorry.
[ Laughter ]
He says, "All federal
legislation sunsets
every five years.
If a law is worth keeping,
Congress can pass it again."
Social Security and Medicare,
Medicaid.
Ron Johnson on Social Security
and Medicare --
"We should transfer everything
so we have to consider
everything every year."
-Now, I do get nervous whenever
Biden tries to use props.
[ Laughter ]
It's like when you sit down
next to an old guy on a plane
and he wants
to show you pictures
of the Thunderbird on his phone.
[ Gravelly voice ]
I had this baby since '62.
Hold on.
Let me -- Ah.
How do I close out
a Candy Crush?
Hold on. Ah!
[ Laughter ]
Oh, now the flashlight's on.
Oh, oh, oh, here we go.
Oh, goddamn it!
That's my niece.
I called her by accident.
Hi, honey!
Hi. I'm with a nice man
on the plane, honey.
I got to go.
So, that's what Biden's
been focused on.
House Republicans, meanwhile,
held a hearing yesterday
that I guess was supposed to be
about censorship on Twitter,
but, in reality, it was just
an opportunity to whine
about how their personal
Twitter accounts were treated
before new owner Elon Musk
took over.
Colorado Congresswoman
Lauren Boebert, for example,
yelled at a bunch
of former Twitter executives
about why her personal Twitter
account had been censored.
Now, I would like you
to watch this clip
and try to decide whether
you're watching an actual adult
[ Laughter ]
at an actual
congressional hearing
or a high school sophomore
yelling at a friend
in the hallway after class.
-Did either of you approve
the shadow banning
of my account, @laurenboebert?
[ Laughter ]
Yes or no?
-No, I did not.
-Not to the best
of my recollection.
-I'll ask again.
[ Laughter ]
Did you shadow ban
my account, yes or no?
-Again, not to the best
of my recollection.
-The answer is, Mr. Roth,
yes, you did!
I found out last night
from Twitter staff
that you suppressed my account
for this tweet.
[ Laughter ]
It's a freaking joke
about Hillary Clinton
being angry
that she couldn't rig
her election!
It's a joke!
But in response,
being the sinister overlords
that you all are,
you placed a 90-day account
filter so I could not be found.
You silenced me
from communicating
with the American people
over a freaking joke!
Now, who the hell do you think
that you are?
[ Laughter ]
-[ As Boebert ]
It was a freaking joke,
Kayleigh!
[ Laughter ]
Okay?
I said it's cool
you won prom queen,
even though you're already
the queen of Bitchistan...
[ Laughter and applause ]
...as a freaking joke.
You overlord!
[ Laughter ]
Then there was
the other Boebert,
Marjorie Taylor Greene...
[ Laughter ]
...who similarly used her time
to scold former
Twitter employees
for suspending her personal
Twitter account
after she repeatedly lied
and spread
dangerous misinformation
about the pandemic
and the COVID vaccine.
Now, just a quick warning
about this clip.
Don't stare directly
into her eyes,
[ Laughter ]
unless you're covering your eyes
with lead-lined oven mitts.
[ Laughter ]
-You can consider your speech
canceled during my time
because you canceled mine.
You see, you permanently banned
my personal Twitter account
and it was my campaign
account, also.
January 2, 2002,
you permanently banned
my Twitter account.
This was the account
that I would put
my campaign ads on...
[ Laughter ]
...raise money on,
fight back when attacked
with lies.
So, while you coordinated
with DHS, the FBI, the CIA,
our government,
and outside groups
to permanently ban, shadow ban,
conservative Americans
and candidates, like me,
and the former president
of the United States,
President Donald J. Trump,
you were censoring
and wrongfully violating
our First Amendment
free speech rights.
And you want to know something?
Guess what.
I'm so glad
that you're censored now
and I'm so glad
you've lost your jobs.
Thank God Elon Musk
bought Twitter.
[ Laughter ]
-The one cool thing
about a Republican-led
congressional hearing is
it answers the question,
"What would Twitter look like
if it was a physical room?"
[ Laughter ]
Also, nothing says
"I'm a champion of the
working class" like --
[ As Greene ]
I'm glad you lost your jobs
when the richest man
in the world
bought the company
you worked for!
[ Laughter ]
You know,
Greene might actually benefit
from Biden's new policies
on airline fees
because she's clearly carrying
a lot of...
-Baggage.
[ Laughter and applause ]
But so what?
You might be thinking
maybe Boebert and Greene
are a little self-obsessed,
but, surely, the other
Republicans in the room
got down to the real issues,
at some point?
Like if Twitter colluded
with the Biden campaign in 2020
to have content they didn't like
removed from the platform.
Now, that might sound
damning to you,
until you find out that, one,
it didn't happen; and, two,
what the specific content
in question actually was.
-Over my right shoulder,
we have an email.
Reference -- This is this
is Saturday, October 24th,
5:39 pm, referencing
five different tweets.
This is --
With a Twitter email chain.
Under the line, it's, "More
to review from the Biden team."
Do you know how many tweets
were actually flagged
and taken down at the behest
of the Biden team?
-I wouldn't agree
with the characterization of it
as being at the behest of them.
These tweets were reported
and Twitter independently
evaluated them under its rules.
-But the email is very clear.
"More to review
from Biden team."
The response, three hours later,
at the bottom.
Hold this up real quick,
so we can see.
The request, at the bottom,
it says, "Handled these."
What does "Handled these" mean?
-My understanding is
that these tweets contained
nonconsensual nude photos
of Hunter Biden.
-[ As Donalds ]
Excuse me, Mr. Roth,
but the American people
are demanding
to see Hunter Biden's nudes!
[ Laughter and applause ]
And you better not make them
pay to see it.
There's nothing worse
than expecting a free peek
at male genitals,
only to find out
there are hidden fees, aka...
-Junk fees.
-Now...
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
...this is what Republicans
are spending actual time on
at a congressional hearing.
Aside from the fact
that no one actually gives
a [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
about any of this nonsense,
it's also just wrong
to say Republicans
are, somehow, victims being
persecuted by social media.
Twitter did field requests
from the Trump administration,
the actual government
at the time,
to remove content
that Trump didn't like.
In fact, it was
reported yesterday
by Rolling Stone that...
And, in the hearing,
a Democratic member
of the committee, Maxwell Frost,
brought up one
of those examples,
which led to some explicit
language being read
into the Congressional Record.
-Earlier, you testified
about a 2019 tweet
that was about President Trump
and I think it's
from Miss Teigen.
What was the tweet about?
[ Laughter ]
-Would you like me to give
the direct quote?
-Yeah.
-Um, please excuse my language.
This is a direct quote,
but Chrissy Teigen referred
to Donald Trump
as a "pussy ass bitch."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Okay. Free speech.
And what happened
after Miss Teigen
[ Cheering ]
posted her tweet,
what did the White House do?
What did the Trump
White House do?
-From my understanding,
the White House reached out
to ask that this tweet
be removed.
-First of all, the way she said,
"Would you like me
to give a direct quote?"
[ Laughter ]
definitely revealed
she was more than happy
[ Laughter and applause ]
to give the direct quote.
She probably carries that direct
quote around with her
at parties. Second...
[ Laughter ]
...I do enjoy that Donald Trump
being called a pussy ass bitch
is now an official part
of the Congressional Record
and only because he complained
about it.
[ Laughter ]
Now, we didn't have to bleep any
of those words.
And, by the way, they weren't
bleeped on C-SPAN, either,
but only because C-SPAN can't
afford a bleep button.
[ Laughter ]
Every now and then,
C-SPAN will like
scrape together enough money
to bring in a guy
to try to bleep stuff live.
-Chrissy Teigen referred
to Donald Trump as a
-Bleep bleep bleep.
-"pussy ass bitch."
-Okay.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Once again, Joe Biden
could not have asked
for a more flattering contrast.
Republicans are using their time
in the House to throw tantrums
about their Twitter accounts
getting suspended
and Hunter Biden's nudes.
Biden, meanwhile,
is laser-focused
on economic populism
and kitchen table issues
that actually matter
to everyday people.
Even called out
Republican Senators Rick Scott,
Ron Johnson, and Mike Lee
for their proposals
to cut Social Security
and Medicare.
Three guys who are also known
by their nicknames...
-"Pussy ass bitch."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-They got to bleep that.
[ Cheering ]
There are probably bleeps there.
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]